hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play cry for your memories out of
it okay I got a crouched young Oh what
happens if I jump on your head
ah no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh
no oh no oh it's another way I'm doing
okay whatever
okay I'm not sticking around this time
to find out I'm not going back I have a
bad I've got bad habit of going back to
look for monsters when they don't chase
me it's just I I don't know why I just
do it oh maybe I gotta give the statue
to this guy maybe that's why he's
standing there I gotta put him in the
[Music]
hey get in here
oh okay hi
you're not in water shut up shut up with
your wet squishy feet doing yeah
whatever big loser
kachunk oh yeah
oh yes I'm the winner
oh yeah I am the winner what aah oh
fudge you fudge you up to Apple oh no oh
no oh no oh no oh I see you there I see
you there
I see you there
oh it's like some guy about legal circus
from how maybe she was a sooner welcome
me I doubt it boom so why did that do it
in one shot
ha Oh Baba Booey oh you got clown makeup
you got clown makeup on somehow this is
even worse I know this game weird with
headshots and whatnot
localized damage is very specific give
me single shot nope
clouds Muscat
oh look at all these ammo huh yeah yeah
oh stop it stop it I I wasn't jumping I
didn't do anything
I don't like this at all
oh I do not like this hi I should kill
all those [ __ ] clowns no joke
ion stand right there
OOP what the hell
there we go I don't what more
look what's going on in my head ooh oh I
retire here kill all the enemies to
advance
[Music]
is this like a Metal Gear Solid thing
what
ah man
got to be sneaky haha right in your fat
head
oh it is oh yeah well not happen oh yeah
I don't know I got it
artists oh hello a boom a bang a home
yeah so I thought ain't got nothing on
me that's right
I'm the best ha ha ha we're going on I
am so confused but then again none of
this is supposed to make sense
Oh
[Music]
what ah
hey big eyes I gotta kill you guys I
didn't even know it could kill you guys
these are modeled after the big guys
obviously I'm willing to bet that
they'll one-shot me if they touch me
plenty of ammo plenty of ammo to do what
I will and what I will is shoot you man
they talk don't doubts about it
okey-dokey
ah I'm worried now because I haven't
even taken one down then again I
probably haven't been shooting one okay
I might to be boned
how do we go one down probably to a he
booked Nikes there we go I guess I've
been hitting them all relatively evenly
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme
hi buddy there we go
good show
[Music]
plus he told us to dream what is going
on anyway
have I been here all this time
Oh what duh that's a guy from afraid of
monsters
[Music]
time is running out for you David Simon
Simon David
[Music]
I like that sweatshirt Chapter eight I
remember Chapter seven
I'm flying by this I wear my reflection
go I could pick up the pills actually
some down there now I guess is trying to
oh no oh no oh no oh boy that's weird
oh man
these were these were some of the
coolest sequences in the crate of
monsters
[Music]
epically I should have done 360 there to
finish it off okay thank you
Oh epic Oh Sulley oh whoops
oh I meant to do that I want to redo the
trick again some so we need more yumping
hues one moment I need to build up my
jumping it stretch out to disappear
there's another gift for you ah damn it
there goes all my jumping use there we
go oh I need to build up but my thighs
again
I don't like that and now I'm exhausted
I don't like hello hello hand hi there
okay that's not the wrong way there is
only one exit well if I was listening to
my inner voice you would say to go right
I have to pick okay not here nope nope
nada no way oh but was that the real one
okay doesn't matter can't go back now
hmm watch out
I got fists of fury no they're just
standing there
excuse me righty-ho then floors gonna
break
[Music]
how did I get here
wait a minute this is oh this is exactly
what this is exactly what afraid of
monsters happened to be Wow awesome yeah
I like this this is exactly yeah let's
see if I remember what to do
it's locked oh I can open it now though
yeah yeah look yeah yeah and if I
remember there was a monster behind
there and there's something in here that
I could get
and here yeah yeah key that's right and
a Glock magazine yeah okay I can't see
but though I thought there was another
yeah there was but something behind that
door I know there is no it'll open later
when a monster comes out I think okay
the same with here okay
yeah I wonder if this is just like a
reintegration of that door open before I
lock is jammed
okay here we go either way I got what I
got to do is um something about turning
off the power I can't see a damn thing
friggin Dirk oh hello ah knife yes a
bloody knife but a knife nonetheless
that guy with the afro okey dokey
that's a fakie fakie reflection illusion
ah yep so far like a pretty faithful
recreation and this will be locked up
here now that I remember and that's
different here we go this is where this
is where you go to turn off the power I
think yeah ah
now where's the gun I got the ammo but
no gun oh this is how you can get
outside that's right
hanged man
I either way I'm out of time for this
episode so it's gonna have to wait until
next time so thank you all so much for
watching hope you're enjoying it I am
really liking this so far lots of cool
stuff going on so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always see you
in the next part bye